do you own a Nintendo switch well the
next system update is live I'm Tony and
this is your new and improved GameSpot
news update
according to Nintendo's website the
switch is to point to point O update ads
quote general system stability
improvements to enhance the user's
experience so yeah that description
gives us basically zero idea of what
this update actually does in an age of
constant patches and updates it would be
nice if Nintendo could give us more
details but for now this is all we have
if you notice any major changes let us
know in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to keep up with all the
Nintendo switch happenings and there's
gonna be a lot of downloading today
considering the switch sold nearly a
million units in its first month in the
States
in fact it's Nintendo's fastest selling
console ever in the US Europe and
Australia if you want more Nintendo
goodness and you're prepared for some
spoilers you can check out Zelda breath
of the wild secret ending right now
[Music]